All right. So what do I do? We got Twitter. Okay, cool.
Uh, remember this whole remember of the gaming, the system guy, dude. Um,
why? Okay.
First of all, Don't
misspell does this guy wrote,
why dos this lady?
Why does this lady Louis bandit Lewis band at six,
six, six, well, any six, six, six. Change it.
But why does this lady have the same first name as your full name?
Chris D'Elia is her crystal. Leah, crystal, Leah,
K R Y S T a L L I a.
How about how her last name is Kelly on Kelly? Antsy. I mean crystal,
Leah [inaudible] I mean the sexiest name of all time,
Chris [inaudible]. Does
she a bond girl? She's a precious, a project manager. Wow. Two likes. Nice bro. Cool. Congratulations Pat. All right. Great. Next one. I don't know, man. You know what you're asking me? I don't know I've become, I get high and tweet
a K you know, and I love how the handle, that's the thing, dude. That's so fun
. The handle is I get high and 21 because they wanted it to be and
tweet. And then, so to let you know their hands they're
header or whatever you would call it, their name on it. I get high in
tweet. Like just have it say Lisa or whatever your name is, dude. We, we
got it. Also change it. Both. I get high in 21, Royal, up
. Are you the lady that fell when the guy threw up, I've become very aware of how much I complained since listening to congratulations,
pod and unexpected life, life lesson. Thank you, senior. Dalea Senor.
I don't, I don't even get that. W w w are you saying? Cause I,
cause I complain or cause I make fun of people who complain or what,
what are you high right now? You're high right now. Dude.
Stop eating so many weed brownies.
Um, yeah, also here's another thing about people. I,
you know, I jokingly call myself daddy and and like, you know,
I call you guys babies.
Don't come up to me and say and call me dad.
People think it's like, nah, I'm not dad, dude,
daddy, all right. People, some guy came up to me and said,
can I get a pick? And he started taking a video and I was like, and I was like,
ah, what are you doing bro? And he was like, Hey, I'm with my dude.
He was so nervous. First of all, he's shaking. And he said, Hey,
what's up Instagram? I'm with my grandpa. Oh
dude, you're a mistake.
I'm with my grand Pappy. Ah,
that was ultimate cringe. I literally on his V I'm on his video going like this.
Ah, what? You get the real deal when you come out, dude.
Uh, okay.
Here's a good one. Rob M at Rob Materra 27. All right, cool.
Find no change in involved.
Saw this woman while driving yesterday and rolled my window down to give her a
drive by, Hey,
your thoughts on this loon and what she's protesting. Okay.
So she's just next to a stop sign.
And this big S banner says
danger. And then under it,
robotic equipment is being implanted into you and your kids during surgery
with your awning, with your informed consent. That with what? Oh,
without your informed consent. Sorry. She's not holding the banner, right?
If you're going to go through the whole trouble, hold the banner, right?
You've got a huge banner. Get a friend. Oh,
but you don't have any because you're alone.
This means slavery. Oh,
it gets real morbid at the end, during surgery, without your informed consent.
This means slavery and torture by remote
control until you die,
dude, this guy took this picture.
What a shot also get a better location.
She's just in,
you know where she is some neighborhood near a stop sign, dude.
Where is it? See if you can see, where did he put that location?
Robot equipment is not being implanted in your who's this
who's holding. Who's behind this sign.
Sam Tripoli dude say Arville New Jersey.
I've played there before. I think, wow man, New Jersey,
nothings. Who's the crazier state, Florida or New Jersey.
I'd have to say Florida because of how big it is. But man,
nothing's more New Jersey than Florida.
Nothing's more New Jersey than a New Jersey guy moving down to Florida and being
in Florida. That's the most New Jersey you can be.
It's like when I found out that, um, a while ago, I don't know if he still does,
but Johnny Depp lives in Paris. I was like, dude,
that's the most Hollywood you can,
nothing's more New Jersey than living in Florida.
And just having a belly, you know like, yeah. You know,
I like it because you know, it doesn't get cold. I can't deal with the cold.
You know, I can't deal with the seasons. I honestly I've.
I've dealt with the seasons for 54 years. I can't deal with it anymore.
I got to come down here. I got to catch some rays. That's it. That's it.
I come out here,
I eat my bologna sandwiches and I smoke a cigar and I'm going to do that.
And I'll tell you what, if it shaves life off the back of my,
the end of my life. It doesn't matter because those are the bad years. Anyway,
I'm talking about I'm living as best as I can from now until I was yes, Stott.
And that's it. And that's it.
Muck bang, YouTube culture.
Brianna Marie prosper at Qataris Pollux. Okay. Change it.
[Inaudible].
Chris, have you talked to muck bang, YouTube culture yet?
Congratulate smart observing report.
It that's my one far is saying people eat a lot of food, muck bang
while they talk while they okay. I'm looking it up.
Muck bang. Oh,
it's that Korean where they eat like squids and, and break,
yeah, that's gross. I can't, I can't watch that.
You know what?
Eating is honestly a private thing.
Even restaurants. It's like, what the are we doing?
We're all getting together to shove in our faces.
It seems like it should be like sex.
You don't. You know, in public and. You don't eating is like an,
it should be like a, it's so intimate.
We're inserting. You know, it's just gross.
Most people, unless you're hot as,
unless you're a nine or above,
you should just be eating by yourself in your house. Dude. If you're at 10,
restaurants should only be for tens. For real.
Like even I, I, I think I, I like to consider myself. I, you know,
I'd like to take care of my body. Like if you try hard, maybe, you know,
with your body and work out and you, you tried, you know,
mostly on only people who should be eating in restaurants or hot chicks that
don't use that much makeup. Cause that's gross to eat with a bunch of makeup on.
Or if you're like a top notch, good looking dude, like
Brad Pitt, Tom cruise, you know what I mean? I'm talking about Paul Walker.
If he was alive, rest in peace. He could be at a restaurant,
maybe Hugh Jackman. I don't really know. I haven't seen him up close,
but like Ryan Reynolds, I guess I could eat with his wife out in public.
But like, bro, you're just going to look like a
grow sky and then put stuff in your face,
in public with other like no Eden private.
So muck bang, go yourself. Okay.
Eating for all the world to see gross.
At least I can click on the link of our PR if I, if I choose,
but like just mostly eating private. Okay.
Private.